you should treat yourself like you're
someone responsible for helping and the
first question is well why don't you and
the answer is well there's a lot wrong
with you you know and it's hard to
exercise enough love and care in a deep
and non-naive way to care properly for
something like that it's an
encouragement to assume to act out the
proposition that even if life is as
difficult as it seems to be and if
you're as vulnerable and weak in a
fundamental sense as you definitely are
and characterized by this terrible
propensity for the infliction of
voluntary suffering on yourself and
others and that destructive tendency
that there's still something within you
that's so remarkable and so aligned with
order and being in the proper manner
that you can climb above that let's say
like able and that you can make the
proper sacrifices and that you can set
yourself right and you can set your
family right and you can set the world
right and that the mere possibility that
that might occur that that might be
within the realm of potential means that
you have a moral obligation to exercise
the responsibility to take care of
yourself as if you're something that
matters and that if you did that
properly it might turn out that what you
did would matter that it would matter to
you that it would be meaningful in the
way that things that matter are
meaningful and that it would matter to
everyone around you need motivation
watch a top 10 believe nation hey it's
evan carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best jordan peterson and my take
on his top 10 was a success
enjoy
rule number two take responsibility if
you've
explicitly formulated a set of goals and
you're pursuing them
then you've adopted the responsibility
to act in a certain manner to make those
goals realize themselves that's
that's responsibility that you've
adopted rather than
responsibility that's been imposed on
you assuming that you've thought through
the goals and you find your spirit in
harmony with those goals
you can consult your resentment i think
that's a very useful step if you find
yourself angry and bitter about the
things that you are responsible for
doing
then
that's an indication that you might be
operating under some
unhealthy compulsion
that you're rebelling and that's the
reason for the resentment against the
insistence that you act in a certain way
although it's also possible that you're
just immature and that you're
rebelling against the discipline that's
necessary to attain the goals that you
genuinely do want to attain and that are
valid and that you
are
what actively engaged in constructing
so
you have to get that straight and some
of that's a consequence of thought and
again some of that's a consequence of of
discussion with other people
with whom you're
intimate enough to have a conversation
like that
and perhaps they have conversations
about similar things with you if you're
fortunate rule number three remain true
to yourself when you were possessed by
those ideas you might have been at least
partially authentic because one of the
things you might ask yourself is well
were they stepping stones to a better
you you know people get possessed all
the time because they admire certain
ideas and sometimes that admiration
impels them into a kind of
apprenticeship and so they were stupider
before they got possessed by that idea
and as they
transf
transformed themselves across the
apprenticeship cycle say being
apprenticed to this
fad like idea they learn something from
it so you know you might
you might have learned and grown as a
consequence of what possessed you now
you know it's possible that a lot of
that spoke
to the development of parts of you that
you don't want to develop
you know that they spoke to your
malevolence and spoke to your desire to
manipulate and all of that and you have
to sort that out but look i also don't
think it's all that easy to
figure out when you're authentic that
that's subtle
you know you you
your felt sense of confidence in your
words when you're not trying to win
is something like your ability to
judge your authenticity you know are you
saying this to achieve a local end or
are you saying this because
you have thought deeply and this is the
best expression you can manage of a
deeply held conviction
that's a lifetime it's a lifetime of
work or it's a lifetime work to sort
those things out the best i could come
up with was in my first book
well the first of the more popular books
in 12 rules for life
um
don't lie
now
not lying is not the same as being
authentic exactly because
as your question highlights it's not
that easy to tell when you're telling
the truth right because well what the
hell do you know it's certainly not the
truth what you know it might be your
best approximation but it's certainly
not the truth and you're by no means
unerring in your ability to discern when
it is that you're even speaking your
truth because that's so complicated you
just have to practice doing that
continually to get anywhere near
good at it like so it's years and years
of effort to
of
stringent moral effort to begin to
manage that but
i do believe that
people can tell by and large when
they're outright lying
and they can stop doing that they can
stop saying things they know to be false
and so that's
the most obvious
impediment to authenticity is
outright
lies of commission
stop engaging in those stop saying
things you know to be false now
that begs the questions how do you know
them to be false well
that's complicated sometimes that's a
feeling of repugnance at your own words
sometimes it's a feeling of touchy
embarrassment so that if people call you
in what you say you get
disproportionately angry
sometimes it's knowing a set of facts
that you haven't let affect the way you
think or present yourself you know
you're purposefully keeping yourself in
the fog as per rule three of beyond
order
those are all things you have to sort
out for yourself but i think it starts
with
an act of faith
and which is at least in part why
religious systems insist upon faith and
faith isn't
belief in something that no one's saying
would believe you know
that's that's a misapprehension of faith
faith is something like
a decision that
truth serves the good
and the good is worth serving and so
therefore truth is worth serving it's a
that's an axiomatic proposition
and you can debate its empirical
justification
and of course we wouldn't be tempted
into temptation if we couldn't debate
its empirical justification because the
objection is
yeah and what exactly does truth buy you
that falsehood wouldn't buy you better
and if you don't think that you're
tempted by that counter position well
then you don't know anything about
temptation because that is the
temptation of the counter position
so and it's powerful temptation that's
why it's a statement of faith that this
that that
conquers it
it's a decision
so
you probably were possessed by an idea
but maybe there was something in you
that was striving to be authentic and
maybe you can speed that process of
transformation
along by vowing by taking a vow and
that's adopting a religious commitment
which is i'm going to serve truth and
the good despite the proximal cost
and that's a statement of faith because
you're staking your life on that
right because every decision you make
from here on in will be
will be
affected by that
by that decision so it's a fundamental
decision
and hopefully that will
guide you
in your endeavor so that your possession
by cultural fads which might be a
necessary part of your apprenticeship
will be temporary and serve this
zigzagging path to something that's
better for you in the future rule number
four find meaning we don't understand
consciousness we don't really understand
its place in the cosmos let's say but
i'm not qualified to answer such
questions
i would say though that no no one stops
listening to a symphony because they
know it's going to end
and so i think in some sense our proper
task is to find the meaning within the
finite when i had clinical clients who
were
consumed with such questions
because you know you can pick a time
frame of evaluation that makes all your
efforts futile right well the sun is
going to envelop the earth i think it's
four billion years so like get ready
it's like well what's the point of
stopping this baby from crying when the
sun is going to envelop the earth and
for well yeah you all laugh right but
but that laughter you see that's a sign
of wisdom
you know that's preposterous
why
i mean that's the existential question
right it's like well if all
if we're all doomed to ashes and decay
why do anything well i used the baby
crying
for a reason
i mean who in the world is going to use
that argument to not feed their baby
well why feed that thing in four billion
years the sun's going to develop the
earth it's like wrong time frame folks
and so what i would say and i did say to
my clinical clients if you're adopting a
time frame that makes what you're doing
appear trivial
the problem isn't necessarily what
you're doing although it might be and
you have to ask yourself that question
because perhaps you are engaging in
something that's more trivial than you
should be the problem is that your
mind which is capable of leaping across
evaluative frameworks has picked a time
frame inappropriate for the task so quit
doing that instead you could say well
why don't you practice adopting the time
frame that imbues your
properly oriented action with the
deepest possible apprehended meaning and
why would you not think that the fact
that that meaning manifests itself with
the proper choice of time frame why
wouldn't you accept the fact that's
indication of a valid choice it
certainly feels like it you know what
you know what it's like you get engaged
in something a deep conversation a piece
of music a piece of art something you
love doing someone you love being with
you get engaged in that you lose your
sense of temporality and you don't pop
out of it and think oh my god i wish i
would use the time frame that made
everything irrelevant because of my you
know cognitive brilliance you think hey
we could do that some more like how
about all the time and that's that's a
good goal it's like yeah how about that
all the time
and then you've got time right when
you're engaged like that and i would say
that's a profound neurophysiological
signal that you're in the right place at
the right time right because it's
accompanied by a sense of deep
well-being and that's literally an
antidote to suffering i i mean that
literally it's
with many of my clients who were
suffering
what we would strive to do was not so
much
make them happy because sometimes that
was impossible they were so
crippled in in so many ways often
physically and in pain
but something meaningful
that would keep them going
and keep them from straying
and keep them from thinking
homicidal and genocidal thoughts all of
that
and meaning that's the antidote to
suffering and the question is well how
is that best to be found well that's an
empirical question you have to you have
to look in your own life and see where
meaning glimmers and then pursue that
right
that's what harry potter is doing by the
way when he's chasing the snitch
i just
thought i'd let you know
and you know you win the game if you
catch that thing
well that's not exactly right you get
100 points but you know it'll do
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five move forward of course
you're going to be disenchanted because
you were young and naive and so
being disenchanted is part of maturing
but the next part of maturing is to move
forward optimistically as an axiom of
your faith in mankind and yourself as a
recognition of your moral obligation to
do so
right so now your eyes are open you see
well you know there's a snake in the
garden
and cain is your brother
well yeah it's always been that way
and welcome to reality
so what do you do you allow that to make
you corrupt and nihilistic
not if you think that it's the
corruption and the nihilism that's the
problem
so you're obligated to be optimistic in
some sense
despite the evidence and that's faith
so you know pick up your cross and
stumble uphill
consciously
and you bring back optimism in human
relations by structuring your own to the
best of your possible ability
and that'll expand outward as you become
more competent move through your life be
productive
generous kind discerning
wise educated
you be a good father
to everyone not the tyrant
that resentment breeds in your own heart
and that's an act of moral courage
and that's real maturity
so and and if you want an adventure well
there's one for you rule number six
avoid nihilistic behaviors is habit
the
the
maintenance the development maintenance
of good practices
habits
if you find yourself
dissolute
neurotic if your tenants if your thought
tends in the nihilistic direction and
you tend to fall apart
organizing your
life
across multiple dimensions is a good
antidote it's not exactly thinking
do you have an intimate relationship if
not well
probably
you could use one
do you have contact with close family
members siblings or children or parents
or or or people who are even more
distantly related if not you probably
need that
do you see your friends a couple of
times a week and do something social
with them
do you have a way of
productively using your time outside of
employment are you employed do you have
a good job or at least a job that
is practically sufficient and that
enables you to
work with people
who you like working with even if the
job itself is
you know mundane or repetitive or
difficult sometimes the relationships
that you establish
within
in an employment situation like that can
make the job
worthwhile
um
have you regulated your
response to temptations pornography
alcohol abuse drug abuse is that under
control
i would say
differentiate the problem
there's multiple
dimensions of attainment
ambition
pleasure responsibility all of that that
make up a life and
to the degree that it's possible you
want to optimize your functioning
on as many of those dimensions as
possible
you might also organize your schedule
to the degree that
you have
that capacity for discipline
do you get enough sleep
do you go to bed at a regular time do
you get up at a regular time
do you eat regularly and appropriately
and enough and not too much
are your days and your weeks and your
months characterized by some tolerable
repeatable
structure
that
helps you meet your responsibilities but
also
shields you
from uncertainty and chaos and provides
you with
multiple sources of reward
those are all the questions that i would
decompose the problem into
the best way to avoid falling back into
nihilistic behaviors and thinking rule
number seven manage your fears people
have like three
well they have four fundamental fears
one is
fear of their own inadequacy and
malevolence that's that's a big fear man
that can really that can really do you
in if you confront it
accidentally
and fully happens to soldiers sometimes
in battle when they find themselves
doing things they can't believe they do
and then we're afraid of society that
would be the oppressive patriarchy
because
society judges us harshly
and
and mercilessly in many ways and we
don't like to plummet in the
what would you call it
we don't like to see our reputation
savaged in front of the groups that we
identify with it's extraordinarily hard
on us emotionally for that to happen
which i wrote about for example in rule
one which is a a
chapter at least in part that details
out the fact that the neurochemical
systems that track your comparative
status incompetence hierarchies also
regulate the balance between your
positive and negative emotion such that
if you suffer a social defeat your
proclivity to experience negative
emotion radically increases and your
proclivity to experience positive
emotion radically decreases and people
seriously do not like that and it's no
wonder because who wants to be
completely overwhelmed with sadness and
bitterness and anxiety and resentment
and disappointment and frustration and
grief and then also devoid of happiness
you know it's the very definition of
hell and if a status defeat will
increase that probability then we will
fight very hard to maintain our status
positions which we certainly do that's
another fear and then of course we have
the fear of nature and we should because
of course nature despite being the
environment and this thing that we
should be striving to protect and
maintain is also trying with all of its
might constantly to make us ill and old
and kill us and is generally very
successful at all three and so there's
every reason to be afraid of nature and
um
you know one night alone in the bush
will pretty much
convince you of that and then people are
also
afraid of the unknown and so those are
the big categories of terror that human
beings face and to be naked on stage is
to face at least
two or three of those
simultaneously rule number eight change
your perception the first thing that you
might want to consider is that the world
is a very complicated place now we've
talked about this before
and the way that you handle there's way
too much complexity for you to handle in
its in its entirety so for example in a
room like this there's an endless number
of
phenomena that you could focus your
attention on right from the sort of
macro phenomena which would be the
overall say color or appearance of the
room to the micro phenomena which would
be the details
at the highest level of detail that
you're able to perceive that litter the
landscape anywhere and so one of the
problems that you have to solve when
you're operating in the world is how you
perceive the world and we do that in
part by making i would say that we
perceive low resolution representations
of the world and we also confuse those
with the world so when i'm looking at
you i'm really looking at a low
represent what i perceive consciously is
a low representation low resolution
representation of you right i only see
the front of you to begin with i only
see your surface
and
in some sense you know i even perceive
you
in some sense as a more or less uniform
color it's hard to tell exactly what
color skin is it's sort of a light pink
roughly speaking but my my perception is
fairly is fairly i don't know what
better way of putting it than low
resolution
and i seem to perceive you at the level
of resolution that's uh that's
sufficient the the
lowest resolution that's sufficient to
facilitate our interactions because i
don't want to clutter up my perceptions
of you when we're just talking with
excess detail so there's lots of things
about you i don't need to see i
certainly can't see any of your micro
structures below the below the
phenomenal level like i can't tell
without tremendous further investigation
what you're made of biologically for
example and i certainly can't perceive
the networks of
society that you're engaged in your
family or the other sorts of networks
that you're embedded in i see you here
now the front of you at low resolution
and you can tell that to some degree and
we've talked about this before because
if you see say animated movies that use
very low resolution representations of
people like uh south park is a really
good example because the imitate or the
animation in south park is very
iconic and and and and simple
it actually makes almost no difference
to following the story and so
that shows you how iconic your
perception really is can be replaced by
very simple icons and you instantly
adapt to that you know so we can go and
see the lego movie batman lego movie for
example and the fact that it's batman
which is an abstraction to begin with
and then it's made out of legos is
almost irrelevant to following the plot
and so some people have compared our
perceptions to the user interface on a
computer you know when you're
interacting with your computer you don't
really interact so to speak with the
computer they're iconic representations
on the screen of the computer that you
interact with and those represent
obviously they share some functional
relationship with what's going on in the
computer but mostly they're there so
that you using your perceptual
structures can interact with the
computer in a manner that's easy for
extremely intelligent apes
roughly speaking now so one of the
problems that you have to solve in the
world because it's so full of detail and
so complex is how do you actually see
the world how do you actually perceive
it and
it isn't really self-evident that that's
a problem
because you think when you look at the
world that it just presents itself to
you but it's a tremendously complicated
problem and that's partly why developing
artificial intelligence systems that can
actually see the world and act in it in
any real way has proved to be a much
more difficult problem than people had
originally supposed because you know we
were told
maybe from the early 60s onwards that
such things as speech to text or object
recognition or
robots that could operate in the world
we're only two or three years away and
well i mean we're in we're in a
situation now where there are some
fairly complicated robots built but
they're still really in their nascent
form and it's because perceiving the
world and then figuring out how to act
and it turns out to be a much more
complicated problem than we originally
thought
because the borders between things are
not self-evident and what level of
resolution you should be perceiving
things at for say maximal functional
utility is also not self-evident it's
also tied up very strangely and in ways
we don't understand with the nature of
your embodiment you know so for example
we tend to see things that are handy
because we can pick them up and
manipulate them and we can make use of
them and so to some degree our brains
are evolved to make the world manifest
itself to us in a set of discrete usable
tools that's that's a reasonable way of
thinking about it and they're discreet
and usable because we have a certain
kind of biological platform you know
because we have hands and mouths and
because we walk in a bipedal manner then
it's logical for us to break up the
world in a manner that makes operating
in this body maximally useful but that
doesn't mean that there's a
straightforward one-to-one relationship
between our perceptions of things and
the things themselves quite the contrary
and that's partly of course we know that
because
with any perceptible object like i could
conceptualize you as one thing
for all sorts of purposes
but
if i'm trying to solve a complex problem
in relationship to you it's going to be
very difficult to determine how to
conceptualize you so if i'm if you come
to me because you're suffering from
a psychological problem of some sort
then i have to figure out you know is it
organic is it is it there's actually
something physiological wrong with you
and i need to know what level of
analysis i would probably conceptualize
you at is it psychological is it and if
it's psychological is it functional like
do you lack the skills or do you lack
the ability to apply the skills or is
there something really going wrong with
your family or maybe it's even a
reflection of an overarching
sociological problem we know for example
that
when the unemployment rate goes up one
percent psychiatric hospitalizations go
up five percent
and so then you might ask well you know
if you're if there's a huge
rise in depression and anxiety across
the population and at the same time
there's a huge increase in in
unemployment you have to ask yourself
what level of perception
would best be suited to solve that
problem because it isn't self-evident
that it's psychological at the level of
the individual
anyways my point is is that perception
is a very difficult problem rule number
nine aim right you're probably not
particularly well suited for jobs that
require a tremendous amount of
transformation of thinking or a
tremendous amount of abstraction but
that doesn't mean there are no jobs for
you
and
so jobs that are more stable and
repetitive
routine let's say
you're better suited for
vocational
jobs
and there's vocational jobs
playing a
remarkably important role in our culture
so and hard work can get you a long ways
and so you know i don't know what you
mean when you say low intelligence
you know i mean there are
catastrophically low intelligence
ratings say 60 and below
it's tough to find anything that you're
going to be able to be productive
in doing
and i don't know what to do about that
above that hard work is going to make a
huge difference
and aiming right
so
aim at the vocational end of the
distribution
and put a plan in place
and stick to it and work diligently at
it that's what you've got you've got
your ability to work
and maybe you can capitalize on your
other personality attributes as well and
as i said already in this podcast you
can do a personality test at
understandmyself.com i would also say
on my
selfauthoring.com website
there's an opportunity for you to map
out a plan
and that's one of the to map out a plan
to write about your past but also to
write about your present self so the
present authoring program enables you to
do an inventory of your personality
strengths and weaknesses and
there's a virtues analysis and a false
analysis and i would say if you're leery
about your future for whatever reason
you should do the virtues analysis it's
like what have you got to offer
and hopefully you have the ability to
work hard and maybe you have other
personality attributes that are
important and that you could understand
and then capitalize on so i would say
do the understandmyself.com personality
test do the virtues section of the
present authoring exercise at
selfauthoring.com
put together a plan and aim at the
vocational end of the job distribution
don't despair there's plenty of
opportunity at that level for someone
who's honest which is a huge advantage
who has integrity who's willing to work
hard
i'm not going to sugarcoat it you know
life is harder at the shallow end of the
gene pool let's say to use scars phrase
from the lion king
we're all at the shallow end of the gene
pool in some regard you know
so
the cognitive end is that's a rough hit
but
general cognitive ability isn't
everything even though it's a lot of
things
and so
aim
integrity hard work
a plan
that's what you've got and so you have
to make the best of it and number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is think carefully i continually
ask my
frequently let's say or yearly ask my
personality class attendees
if they heard
the voice of conscience if they had a
feeling an emotion
emotional state let's say or of voice
that informed them when they had done
something ethically wrong and that
perhaps made them guilty as a
consequence and
it was essentially a universal
experience and that's the voice of
society within i suppose
that's one way of thinking about it the
freudians would think about that as the
voice of the superego
jung carl jung would take that
conceptualization somewhat farther he
would have considered it the voice of
the self
which is
in part
the voice of
the ethic that's derived from the
broader community insofar as that ethic
is valid let's say but also in part
the voice of the
more
thoroughly developed self that's still
striving to be born
one thing you could say is that
you
you experience violations of your
conscience
when you're not acting like the better
person that you could possibly become
and so
to some degree that's your higher self
upgrading you for failure to develop in
the appropriate direction and
that seems to me to be
a reasonable way of conceptualizing it
now the one question might be
how error prone
is your conscience given that you're not
omniscient and
i have an endless fascination with the
movie pinocchio
and part of that is because it taught me
something very sophisticated about
conscience in that movie
jiminy cricket is given divine
attributes he has the same initials as
jesus christ for example and
um
he
is deemed
the voice of conscience itself by
by the magical properties of of mother
nature essentially but in the movie
it's necessary for the puppet
who's still wooden headed and still a
marionette whose strings are being
pulled by others it's necessary for the
puppet to engage in a dialogue with his
conscience because
both of them have to inform
the other
and that seems to me
approximately right because
i certainly saw people in my clinical
practice and no people in my private
life who
seem to
labor under a two
authoritarian
labor under the dictates of a too
authoritarian
conscience uh maybe that's the
internalized voice of a relatively
tyrannical father for example
uh
or
you know exaggerated sensitivity to the
moral pressure exerted by the broader
social world
you have to
attend to your
guilt and your self-disgusting your
self-contempt and your
self-consciousness
you have to
understand that the manifestation of
those emotions
might well indicate a moral failing on
your part or a
uh
a lack that needs to be addressed
well at the same time considering that
it is not a straightforward
matter
to deal fairly with yourself and
you can be too tormented by your
conscience too rigid
too responsible
take on too much weight onto yourself
deny yourself in a manner that isn't
sustainable
and so forth that that a moral
code a moral way of being can become too
rigid and
and inflexible
and despite its putative aim upward
be something counterproductive
i think most of
the way out of that if there is one is
well careful thinking
you have to see what your conscience
says you have to see
how you respond
you have to capture
that voice and your responses and you
have to think it through but
most of that is done in dialogue with
other people rather than as the
consequence of internal thought
you know if you have a
dispute with your wife or your husband
your intimate partner sibling
your parents anybody close to you
and it's useful to for each of you in
the dispute to
ask yourself and the other person very
seriously
if you're at fault
or if they're at fault and and for both
of you to be able to
contemplate
that you might be at fault and so might
the other person and that it's in your
best interest to sort out exactly
who's made the error and where and maybe
it's both of you and maybe at different
levels of analysis
i think the same might be said about
your reaction to your conscience
it's not
uncommon for me to talk to my wife my
kids my parents
my friends for that matter
about something i might be feeling maybe
i'm guilty about something i'm
self-conscious about something i'm
angry about something
um
i feel impelled by my conscience to do
something as a consequence
to change something
it's very helpful to discuss such things
with other people
to say look here's
what i think i did wrong and here's how
i'm punishing myself but i'm not sure
that i'm not doing it in an exaggerated
way and
you gather other people's opinions and
listen to them carefully and
friends are extraordinarily useful in
that regard and that can help you
calibrate it
so
i think most of what we do to decide if
our inner voice is healthy is discuss it
with other people and i believe as i
pointed out in my last book uh
explicitly that
tremendous amount of our sanity is
maintained
as a consequence of social interaction
so
you can't find your authentic self
merely as a consequence of a journey
within i would say
you you're not there's just not enough
of you
you have to be informed by the broader
social world
you speak about the concept of the soul
do you associate this with any
psychological constructs
not any psychological constructs that
are more valid than the notion of the
soul
you know there's
there's i would say what we mean by soul
is something like animating spirit
and you might say well what's a spirit
and well
that's actually rather easy to answer so
when a child of four is playing house
let's say when a child of four is
playing house she
acts out the role of the mother
but acting out that's a strange thing
right because she doesn't literally
duplicate in her actions or her
perceptions in the game
what she observed her mother literally
doing so for example she didn't go into
her mother's bedroom when her mother
awoke and watched her turn her head in a
particular way to awaken and count the
number of blinks so that she can mimic
that in her play
and you know you think that's absurd but
it's not absurd if it's just mimicry
it's not it's unbelievably sophisticated
so what the girl does is she watches her
mother manifest maternal behavior across
a vast array of instances and she
integrates that with the image of the
mother she's received from all the books
she's been read and all the little
movies she's watched the disney movies
and so forth and she abstracts out the
animating principle of the maternal and
then she embodies that in play and
usually with a little boy and that's
practice for what's going to come later
it's unbelievably sophisticated and
she's embodying a spirit and the spirit
there is the abstraction of the central
animating principle from multiple
embodiments of its manifestation and if
you think children can't do that well
then you don't know anything about
children because they do that all the
time in their pretend play which is a
necessary precursor to healthy
psychological development and so part of
what we refer to as the soul is the
presence of that spirit or maybe even
the capacity of embodying such spirits
and it's very difficult to know how deep
that goes
you know i had a vision at one point of
all the men in my life who've been
particularly influential in a benevolent
way
you know and so and you think well just
a mirror notion of the idea that there
could be a benevolent way
that would unite the acts of benevolence
across a series of men that's all
comprehensible to you that's you take
that as a matter of course when you say
that there are such things as good men
and you can identify them right
something stable about whatever is good
across multiple manifestations of of
incarnation let's say and i saw that
transform into the
the father person of the trinity as the
embodiment of that benevolent spirit now
i don't have any idea what that means
metaphysically because who does but
but that
that spirit manifesting itself within is
certainly part of what we refer to when
we talk about the soul and you can see
that shine through people
i mean it's part of what gives someone
charisma
it's part of what elicits the instinct
to imitate in you
you know when you see that even in
simple things when you see a remarkable
athlete do something
incredibly
athletic to put the goal to put the
soccer ball the football ball through
the net
to score the goal and everybody leaps to
their feet in celebration of that well
that's that's a celebration of the
divine capacity to hit the target dead
on and it grips you at such a lo a low
level way down inside your soul that
you're compelled to your feet to cheer
and you don't even know what you're
doing
but you enjoy it that's for sure and
that enjoyment is also a sign of
the depth and utility of that response
you see this and all all the things that
people do that are you know so-called
popular entertainment it's unbelievably
sophisticated the soul is participating
in that in the fullest extent and you
know you can say well there's no use for
the religious there's no necessary use
for the religious terminology it's like
well until you come up with a better
word there's plenty of use for it
because it's a very complex and deep
phenomena and to you know just
cast it into the realm of superstition
in some
casual manner is
it's just not helpful not in any
possible it's not helpful scientifically
it's not helpful ethically it's not
helpful existentially
try treating someone for a while as if
they don't have a soul
just really i mean it just you know
treat them like a deterministic machine
if that's your belief really act it out
you'll be like the most hated person in
town in about 15 minutes well i mean
what do you make of practical evidence
like that
i mean you interact with people as if
they're
free souls capable of choosing between
good and evil that's what you do all the
time
and maybe you can addle yourself out of
that by some ridiculous rationalist
ideology but that just means you're
kind of a gabbling fool and it's just
going to
make you trip over things you don't even
notice in all of your social
interactions and you tell me i don't
care how you think philosophically or
ideologically you bloody well know that
what i just said is true
so and that's true even when you're
interacting with an infant or a small
child it's true when you're dealing with
someone who's elderly and virtually
incapacitated in every way you still see
that divine spark for lack of a better
term and we do lack a better term by the
way you see that everywhere if your eyes
are open and if you're willing to see it
and to the degree that you're responsive
to that then
your actions are guided by love and your
words are guided by truth you have to
make a decision in your life
and this is
this is a decision and i would say that
it's a voluntary element of faith
because it isn't exactly evidence-based
it's more like something you decide
before you even look at the evidence
it's more like you decide to stake your
life on this like you know if you decide
to get married to someone you don't
really do it on the basis of the
evidence that you're going to have a
happy life because you don't have that
evidence you do it you decide that
you're going to make a happy life with
this person and that it's worth the risk
so you you get married as an expression
of faith
okay and and so faith doesn't mean
believing things that no one with any
sense would believe faith sometimes
means putting a stake in the sand and
saying here's where i stand
in some sense regardless and you do that
when you get married you do that maybe
when you you know pledge allegiance to a
friend you have a best friend and you
want to maintain that friendship as long
as you possibly can it's
it's it's a decision of faith um maybe
you do that when you decide a career
when you go to university because you
could have done something else right but
you chose that so that's where you put
your faith
um and like i said that doesn't mean
believing what no reasonable person
would believe
okay so back to god is love well i'm
gonna talk about being first instead of
god
um
and being is the totality of experience
that we're gonna define that it that way
for the purposes of this discussion
being is what there is instead of
nothing and you experience that as a
conscious creature
being is what you experience as a
conscious creature it includes all your
emotions all your motivations all your
subjective experience
as well as everything that's objective
okay so
it seems to me that all things
considered
it's
a useful
move of faith
to act
as if you love being and if you love
something then you want the best in it
to flourish and so maybe you decide deep
in your soul that
it would be better for you to act
towards an end that
makes everything that's good better that
that's the best way to live to make
everything that's good better and maybe
to restrict the development of
everything that's malevolent and evil
within yourself and in the broader world
in so far as you're able to do that and
so i think that's an expression of love
is that because when you love something
you care for it and the proper attitude
towards being i think is care
and so
so that's one element of god is love
god being
analogous in some way to being um
now we could look at god more
classically as the creator of being if
you assume being is good well it's not
much of a leap to assume the creator of
being is good and maybe you adopt an
attitude towards the creator of being
and that's also love and you open your
heart to existence and
maybe that's the most effective means of
having existence open its heart to you
so for example you know if you
love other people you want the best for
them you want the best in you to serve
the best in them if you love them and
you trust them courageously so you open
yourself up to them
i don't think it's unreasonable to
assume that that's how you elicit the
best from them the best that can be
elicited you're going to get hurt
sometimes and betrayed but that's going
to happen no matter what approach you
take i think that's the most effective
approach and that is perhaps the most
effective approach to existence per se
to approach it with love and courage
and
and so
that's
how that looks to me
is it feeling like loving a person yes i
think it is i think it is a feeling like
loving a person it's it's the
generalization of that care that you
would have for
a child your child your your brother
your sister a family member it's the
generalization of that to the broader
domain of
of existence to broader domain of
domains of existence and i think that's
a skill in some sense right i mean if
you're
good at loving and caring for your
family but you can
expand that outward so that more people
are brought under that umbrella then
well assuming you can manage that's very
difficult
it seems to me that that's laudable it
seems to me that we spontaneously admire
and would like to imitate people who are
capable of that
and so
you see that when you have a job or you
and you encounter a boss who takes you
under his or her wing and helps develop
you or
you find a teacher who's particularly
inspiring or you work for an
entrepreneur who's inspiring and who
also opens doors for you um
they're acting with love as far as i'm
concerned they want the best in them to
serve the best in you and that's very
very motivating for everyone and
that's the proper basis of our social
relationships not power for god's sake
so
can love balance out the crushing
responsibility
that's a sophisticated question
i don't know the answer to that
love is warmer than responsibility love
is the is part of empathy and
agreeableness it's a different dimension
than responsibility which is more part
of conscientiousness than sort of a cold
virtue
i don't know if it balances out the
crushing responsibility but i think it's
the emotional analog to the crushing
responsibility
right so maybe there's love and duty and
they run parallel in in if you're an
ethical person that's not all there is
to ethics but you know love and duty
they're
they're important and and maybe they're
better together than they would be as
independent um entities when i was 25 or
so i probably weighed about 138 pounds i
smoked like pack cigarettes day i drank
tremendous amount of alcohol i was from
northern alberta this rough little town
up in northern alberta called fairview
and you know there were long winters
there and my friends were heavy drinkers
and most of them dropped out of school
by the time they were 15 or 16 went off
to work on the oil rigs and you know it
was a rough town and we drank a lot i
started when i was 14 and you know um
and so
i was i had a lot of bad habits let's
say and uh
things that were and i wasn't in great
shape physically and i was also still
intellectually obsessed by as i am now
and uh
so that would have been that would have
been in 85 but when i but i decided
around that about 85 84 something like
that maybe a little earlier that i was
really going to try to get my act
together and uh
so i started doing that i you know i
first of all i
i quit smoking oh that took a long time
because i eventually had to quit
drinking too in order to quit smoking
and i
started working out starting playing
sports which i'd never done i had a fine
time when i was a kid and but
i needed really to get disciplined
i had to do it because
i was working on these hard problems
that you know that i've been discussing
with all of you and i've been working on
them really you know obsessively since
i was probably about 18 maybe even
earlier than that
got to the point around 25 when i was in
graduate school trying to get my phds
doing all my research like i published
15 papers by the time i graduated with
my phd which was by i think by a fairly
large measure the most papers that any
un graduate student at that time had
ever published at mcgill i think that's
right might have been twice as many or
maybe twice as many maybe even three
times as many and at the same time i
wrote maps of meaning which was a
terrible terrible
terribly difficult thing to do because i
was writing about three hours a day
doing that and i couldn't do all that
and continue with my misbehavior you
know my sort of
my
what would you say my my
my hedonistic
my hedonistic
my massive hedonistic consumption of
alcohol and all of that i just couldn't
keep it up and also work seriously on
the issues that were at hand so you know
i had to stop that's a sacrifice i had
to stop
messing about and straighten myself out
you need that instinct for meaning too
so and we should get this real straight
why do you need it
well you need it because life is really
really difficult right i mean
people have a rough time of it there's
plenty of suffering in life and everyone
is going to encounter it right there
you don't you know you learn this as a
clinical psychologist and you know this
generally you know unless you're an
extraordinarily fortunate person
um you don't have to talk to someone for
very long
and and really talk to them and get
beneath the surface until you find you
know there's a tragedy or two or three
or ten lurking not very far beneath the
surface someone in the family is very
ill there's a childhood history of
extreme pathology alcoholism somewhere
in the family maybe a touch of insanity
someone has cancer you know someone some
an older relative is dying there's
financial trouble there's economic
trouble there's marital trouble it's
like life is trouble and now you know it
that doesn't mean it's all trouble but
man it's trouble and sometimes it's it's
a lot of trouble and sometimes it's so
much trouble that you can you can barely
stand it and and you see that because
people you know people get depressed and
they commit suicide and the reason they
do that is because they think not being
is better than being and that's quite
the decision you know so and and it's
not that uncommon among people who are
depressed and so it's it's it's a very
it's a very important thing to consider
and it and it isn't just a matter of
depression and suicide that's bad enough
but you know if you're unhappy because
your suffering has pushed you past the
point of your ability to cope then
there's all sorts of other things that
can happen to you that aren't directed
towards you you can become cynical and
you can become bitter and you can become
cruel and you can become narcissistic
and deceitful and arrogant and and it's
like everything's for you and then
you're out for revenge that's a nice one
i don't know against who but maybe
everyone maybe even including you
because you're not happy about the role
you've played in generating your own
misery i mean there's a lot of darkness
underneath the suffering and so and and
that's that's an ever-present
existential danger for human beings you
know we're aware of the future we're
aware of our fragility we're aware of
our mortality it's something that makes
us truly unique truly conscious in a way
that no other creature is and capable of
things that no other creature can do but
also bearing an unbelievably heavy
existential load we're the only
creatures that have to always contend
with the fact that we're finite and that
everyone we know is in the same position
that allied with the suffering and so
that's there all the time and and you
know even even in in the brightest
moments in some sense you know in in in
renaissance paintings in still life they
used to put a momento
momento mori often in the in the still
life like a skull somewhere in the
corner or sometimes sometimes in
in a very strange perspective so that
you could only see the skull if you were
standing like right beside the painting
instead of dead on but the idea was to
always remember you know that everything
that exists is tainted or touched with
the with the with the with it with the
taint of mortality and you know that's
rough but there's some useful things in
it it keeps you awake and it keeps you
focused if you're careful but it also
does
indicate to you if you think about it
the necessity of having a meaning in
your life because
because
if it's true intrinsically that life has
this unbearable element of suffering
which seems to be completely in in what
would you say indisputable as far as i'm
concerned and it's worse than that too
because it's not just suffering it's
suffering contaminated with malevolence
right it's bad enough to have something
bad happen to you and it's likely that
that'll happen but it's even worse for
you to do it to yourself and to know
that you did it that's rough and it's
also extraordinarily rough to be
betrayed by someone else or you know
tyrannized by your own culture and so
and that's that's not just suffering
that's like unnecessary and pointless
suffering that's been directed at you by
something that wants that to happen and
so both of those are very very powerful
let's say archetypal forces suffering
and malevolence and we have to deal with
them at every level of reality and you
need something to you need something to
push back against that it's not optional
if that's the default position and i
think it's the default position like a
meaningless life isn't meaningless
it's suffering and malevolence
that's not good and and if that's acted
out you know that's the other thing if
that's acted out and i've read the
accounts and the actions of people
who've
taken a very
vicious turn into the darkest parts of
the underworld consequence of their
resentment and their malevolence and
then their desire to make everything in
the world suffer for the outrage of its
existence man i mean that's how we turn
things into hell if you want to know why
totalitarian states take the brutal
twists they take and why people are
motivated to do the absolutely terrible
things that they do well that's why is
that the suffering and the malevolence
that's intrinsic to life overwhelms them
and and they turn and they turn in a
very bad direction and then they make
everything that's already bad way worse
and we're very very inventive at such
things and so
that's not good unless that's the path
you want that's a bad idea you need an
alternative and that's meaning your
perceptual structures are determined by
the goals that you have at hand i mean
some of that's that's not completely
true because your perceptual systems
also have limitations right there's
things you can't see or hear even if you
need to so there are limitations built
in but within that set of limitations
you're still trying to tune your
perceptions to your motivated goals and
that's also very useful to think about
when you're trying to understand
artificial intelligence because for
human beings without goals there's no
perception because there's no filtering
mechanism that you can use to determine
the level of resolution at which you
perceive anyway so there's the there's a
thing made of smaller things which are
made out of smaller things and it's so
it's kind of my iconic representation of
the complexity of the world and then you
could think well what is this how can
you see this object and i think if you
just look at it
you can
detect it's like a necker cube you know
those cubes that
that are line drawings that you can see
the front of and then it'll flip to the
back have you seen those
so this is kind of necker cube like or
at least it is for me in that when i
look at it
my perceptions play around with it
sometimes i focus on the kind of cross
like shape in the middle and sometimes i
can see these other lines and then
sometimes i'll focus on that square and
sometimes i can see the little dots
there or maybe one dot and my
perceptions are going like this trying
to fit a pattern to it and i you can
kind of detect that when you're watching
it and so i would say well you have the
options of perceiving this in its full
complexity or you can simplify it
essentially
there's lots of ways you can simplify it
but some of them are laid out there so
you take the complete complex thing you
make a low resolution representation of
it
so that's it's rough that's the rough
area that all those dots occupy that's
the rough area broken down to its four
most fundamental quadrants that might be
how you would look at it if if this was
a map of an orchard and you were trying
to walk from south to north that would
be a useful representation this combines
this and this that's
that's the highest level of resolution
that you can perceive this object at
that's lower resolution than the object
itself
so the first issue is how should you
look at things well that's a problem
that intelligence has to solve so that's
one of the problems that intelligence
goes after and then i think what happens
is we have the thing in itself
and then we simplify it with a
perception
and that's like an iconic representation
and then we we nail the iconic
representation with a word and that's
how we compress the world's complexity
into something that we can manage we
take the complex thing make it into an
icon and represent the icon with a word
and then when i throw you the word so to
speak you decompose it into the icon and
then decompose it even further into the
thing if you can't if you know the icon
and you know the thing and so then we
can use shorthand right because you have
representational structures and so do i
and i'm just tossing you markers about
your representational structures and you
can unfold them that's what you do
when you're reading a novel
because the novel comes alive in your
imagination in your own idiosyncratic
way and it wouldn't if you didn't
understand the references of the novel
right the novelist has to assume that
your basic perceptual structures and
your intuitions and your instincts are
basically the same as his or hers
because otherwise they have to assume
that because otherwise they would be
lost in an infinite regressive
explanation
so and it's problematic
often for example if you start reading
victorian novels you may find that it
takes a while to get into them because
the presuppositions the expectations are
slightly different and so is the
language you have to update the
representations i don't know how many of
you have read dostoevsky's crime and
punishment but i would highly recommend
that in crime and punishment the
protagonist
commits the perfect murder and he has
his reasons for it and many reasons
because dostoevsky didn't mess around
when he wanted to give someone reasons
he gave them reasons and raskolnikov the
main character had reasons for murder
and then he commits his murder and he
gets away with it
but things don't go well for skalnikov
because one of the things he finds out
is that the raskolnikov that you were
before you committed the murder
is not the same as the raskolnikov as
you are after you've committed the
murder and there's a dividing line there
that you don't
it's like the red pill i guess right
it's like in that's the matrix correct
the red pill
and
once there's certain actions once you
take them there's no going back
and so that's what crime and punishment
is about and ruskolnikov tortures
himself to death well not literally but
metaphysically psychologically because
he cannot tolerate
breaking the great moral code
and so it's a great book it's truly a
great book and and it's also
extraordinarily like it's a it's a it's
a it's a murder mystery thriller as as
well as being a deep philosophical book
so if you're in the mood for you know a
murder mystery thriller that's also a
deep philosophical book then that's the
one for you human consciousness is that
faculty that confronts potential itself
i think there's good neurological
evidence for this by the way for those
of you who are scientifically minded
because
we build
circuits
within us for habitual action that we've
practiced many times that seem to run in
a very deterministic fashion
and we are a strange combination of
deterministic and non-deterministic as
far as i can tell but what our
consciousness seems to be for is to
encounter those things that we have not
yet encountered
and those things that we have not yet
encountered seem to me to be those
things that have not yet been brought
into being and so you could say that
what our consciousness is for is
for the encounter with potential you
know that our consciousness is for the
it's not for the past it's not even for
the present
it's to transform the future into the
present and then really that that's what
our consciousness does when you wake up
in the morning you have a new day ahead
of you and the day could take you in
very many directions and and the weeks
and the years all of that can take you
in very many directions and you have
some apprehension about what those
directions might be
you have some apprehension about
what role your choices might
make in transforming that potential into
one form of actuality or another i mean
you certainly know that there are
dreadful mistakes that you might be very
tempted to make that would produce all
manner of hell around you and still be
tempted to do it it seems like it's
sitting there right in front of you as a
possibility you also know that you know
you could haul yourself up out of bed
and attend to your duties and do the
sorts of things that you're supposed to
and said a few things right that day and
that week and that
likely
things would at least not be worse and
they would probably be better and i i
believe that i do believe that i don't
understand how this can be the case i
don't understand
how it is that consciousness
consciousness can function in that way
because i think to understand that
we would have to understand what it
means for the future to be only
potential rather than actuality and who
the hell understands that i mean no one
and then we'd have to understand how it
is that our conscious choices and our
conscious ethical choices
transform that potentiality into
actuality into reality into the present
and the past and we certainly
but we certainly act as if we believe
that that's what we do we upgrade
ourselves for example when we do a bad
job of it we're upset with our children
and those we love if we don't believe
that they're living up to their
potential we're guilty and ashamed when
we make choices that we feel are
inappropriate we understand to some
degree that the manner in which time
lays itself out has something to do with
the ethics of our choice and again i
would say that's a very deep idea
i think it's uh i think it's
i think it's the most true idea i know
it's very
emphasized that idea emphasized in
ancient religious stories such as those
that are outlined in genesis or in
genesis with its strange insistence that
you know god is that which
brings order out of chaos formless
potential generates the world out of
formless potential and that we're
somehow made in that image which which
seems to me to be the case and that the
proper way by the way to go about
acting in that image
is to act in relationship to the
potential that confronts you with truth
and with courage with careful
articulation that's the logos and that
if you do that then what you bring forth
is is good part of the
cultural battle that we all find
ourselves enveloped in is
partially due to the claim that there's
virtually nothing other than the lust
for power
and you know i would say
fair enough in some limited sense
which
and that's
that bears directly on your question
because
you see that as a temptation that might
be powerful enough to bend and distort
you as you attempt to make your way
through let's say the halls of power
well
[Music]
i heard recently from a reliable source
that putin's conversion to orthodox
christianity might be genuine
and then you might think well if you're
atheistic
well that's not necessarily a good thing
or maybe you think it's a bad thing or
maybe you think it's
an irrelevant
issue and you may also think it's a lie
but
i would say that
i would be more inclined to trust
someone who thinks there's something
higher than himself
and then you might say well what is it
that's higher than ourselves and that's
worth thinking about and we all need to
think about this regardless of the
particulars of our religious belief and
i would say
again from a clinical perspective
service to others is really something
people who are depressed tend to use the
pronouns i and me
much more frequently than people who
aren't depressed and i'm not saying that
people get depressed because they're
selfish i'm not saying that at all i'm
saying that
one of the way out one of the roots out
of depression appears to be
an increase in service to other people
and i think the reason for that is
because we aren't power mad demons at
the core even though we may be tempted
by such things and that we find
the genuine meaning that offsets genuine
suffering in the genuine service to
others and i think it's a big mistake to
be cynical especially prematurely about
such things as political activity
because they're necessary despite let's
say their adversarial and uh
and uh
party-centered nature partisan nature
you have to be clear about what you
serve
and why
and that has to be held higher always
than mere victory mere
operationalized victory or instrumental
victory it's a very very difficult thing
to negotiate particularly because in the
political realm
in some sense you have to defeat your
enemy right because you have to win the
election and the other people have to
lose it's a binary choice but so often i
see in partisan discussion the
proclivity to assume that all the ill
will and malevolence resides on the
other side of the chamber
and that's a big mistake and you can
think about that more deeply too is that
we all have to put we all need a place
to place the existence of malevolence
right because malevolence clearly exists
and we're all suffer from the weight of
malevolent history
right because even the grounds we walk
on here which this is a remarkable and
wonderful place i mean english soil is
soaked with blood just like the soil of
every place in the world that's part of
the human heritage and all of us bear
the marks of that conflict in some sense
in our souls partly because of the
possibility for us to engage in that but
also partly because part of the reason
we're here in all this privilege is
because of all that catastrophe
well the best way to localize that
malevolence is inside you
right and to remember that the enemy
that you're fighting with the greatest
enemy that you ever fight with is in
your own heart and that'll also stop you
from confusing
that true source of malevolence let's
say with your mere political enemies and
that isn't to say that you won't
encounter malevolent behavior although
most of it in the political sphere as it
is everywhere most of it is more
ignorance than malevolence although
willful blindness certainly plays a
large role and so you need to know
what it is that you're serving and i
would say one of the ways to do that
practically or a couple of ways to do
that practically is you need a good team
around you the people you really trust
and who can watch you
and who do it with a certain degree of
impartiality and who are disagreeable
enough to talk to you when you do
something wrong so you need trusted
advisors and then the other thing i
would say is you really need to listen
to your constituents
because they will tell you what the
problems are if you listen to them and
if you really listen to them well then
you'll have your feet on the ground
which is where they should be
and you'll know what the problems are
and you will win elections
because what people really want from
their leaders is to be listened to and
then for those leaders to articulate
what they've heard in the halls of let's
say influence and power
and so if you know those things if you
know you need to listen you need to get
in touch with the people you're
representing as regularly as you
possibly can and mostly to listen
um i knew a man in canada who started a
political party which is very difficult
thing to do and not only did he start it
but he wrote it to sufficient success
though that he became the leader of the
opposition in canada within about 10
years
and i asked him how he did that because
it's like well really how did you do
that that's actually really hard
and he said he would go out from
constituency to constituency and make
his stump speeches but what he really
liked was the q and a's because people
would tell him what their problems were
then he knew what the problems were and
out of the dialogue would also emerge
the answers that the audience found
compelling and so not only would they
tell them what the problems were but
they would tell them the answers they
would like to have it have have what
instituted to solve those problems
it's the same thing that comedians do
when they
when they finesse finesse their acts in
front of live audiences before they
practice them in front of a large
audience they lit they tell jokes and
the audience either laughs or they don't
if they laugh then you keep that joke
and if they don't you throw it out and
soon you're just as funny as the
audience can possibly manage and it's
the same thing you can also do that in a
dark manner by the way which is what
hitler did
so he could utter terrible things and
wait for a response and collect those
and so then you become the embodiment of
the shadow of your people
so i would recommend that you probably
don't do that you're going to have to
put some effort into your life
and you need to be motivated to do that
and so what are the potential sources of
motivation well you could think about
them in the big five
manner you know if you're extroverted
you want friends if you're agreeable you
want an intimate relationship if you're
disagreeable you want to win
competitions if you're open you want to
engage in creative activity if you're
high neuroticism you want security okay
so those are all sources of potential
motivation that you could draw on that
you could tailor to your own you know
your own personality but then there are
dimensions that you want to consider
your life across and so we ask people
about
well you know if you could have your
life the way you wanted it in three to
five years if you were taking care of
yourself properly you know what would
you want from your friendships what
would you want from your intimate
relationship how would you like to
structure your family what do you want
for your career well how are you going
to use your time outside of your job and
how are you going to regulate your
mental physical mental and physical
health and maybe also your drug and
alcohol use because that's that's a good
place to augur down you know because
alcoholism for example wipes out you
know five to ten percent of people so
you want to keep that under control and
then
and then so maybe you know you you you
develop a vision of what your life what
you would like your life to be and that
associates
the
so the goal once the goal is established
and then you break down the goal into
micro processes that you can implement
the micro processes become rewarding in
proportion in relation to their uh
causal association with the goal and
that tangles in your your incentive
reward system you know we talked about
the dopaminergic incentive reward system
and that's the thing that keeps you
moving forward and the way it works is
that it works better
if it produces positive emotion when it
can see you moving towards a valued goal
okay well what's the implication of that
better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation working out and so the more
valuable the goal in principle the more
the micro processes associated with that
goal start to take on a positive charge
and so what that means is while you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about the day you're ready to go and so
as far as i can tell what you do is you
specify your long-term ideal
maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified to fail as well as
excited about succeeding because that's
also useful you specify your goal you do
that you do that in some sense as a
unique individual you want you want to
specify goals that make you say oh if
that could happen as a consequence of my
efforts it would clearly be worthwhile
because the question always is why do
something because doing nothing is easy
you just sit there and you don't do
anything that's real easy the question
is why would you ever do anything and
the answer that has to be because you've
determined by some
means that it's worthwhile and then the
next question might be well where should
you look for worthwhile things and one
would be well you could consult your own
temperament and the other would be well
you kind of look at how
look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the lifespan
look look what so you do a structural
analysis of the subcomponents of human
existence and already did that
you need a family you need friends like
you don't need to have all these things
but you better have most of them family
friends career educational goals plans
for you know time outside of work
attention to your mental and physical
health etc you know those are that's
what life is about and if you don't have
any of those things well then all you've
got left is misery and suffering so
that's that's a bad
that's a bad deal for you
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn how to stop the
procrastination check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and see you there
execution the carrying out and putting
into effect
of a plan order or course of action
putting it into effect execution
i put it into effect